asking you to name a double standard
that doesn't benefit me because you're
not quite getting what you're talking
about
i don't think there is that's the truth
that that's the truth so i i have a stat
for you guys harvard so this is you
would you say harvard can gather
research effectively it depends what
islam oh god
the numbers are skewed
harvard says 70
of abuse is women against men
why do we why do we only hear about
violence against women because men don't
talk about it enough
men don't really complain too much
they'll just take it back
and why are there more women's shelters
than men because of the consequence of
the violence no i i don't think
are you talking about homeless shelters
and that because if it is stuff like
that as well even with the homelessness
in london because i always do like
um do stuff for the homeless every year
and that and you never really see women
on the street and it's always and
there's a lot of white men on the street
as well so it's not just a thing where
it's like well if you're a man you can
be homeless
i believe i'm saying i'm saying i'm
saying there's women's shelters but
there's not men's shelter yeah what kind
of shows that's what i'm saying because
i know i know there's also women's
battered women because there's also
women's homeless shelters as well so
like they get taken into certain places
that men don't yes i'm saying battered
there's battered women's shelters and
other shelters they actively turn down
men whoa
so we're sorry go ahead yeah i was just
commenting on what he said that we find
more uh homeless men than women
it's it's it's just because we would
take care of women more than them
right
but then it goes back to like women
don't face consequences if a man's on
the street he's homeless if the women's
on the street there are many more
shelters and resources for her yeah this
is that's an interesting point because i
think there is you know people talk
about that glass ceiling but there's
like a cushioned floor that women tend
to go to where men don't so if i'm if
i'm poor i have as a man i know that no
woman is going to marry and marry me and
you know
raise me up and put me in the house but
that there's a possibility that it could
happen to you as a woman
so
you don't know about homosexuals
you don't know about them
men who don't what's the what's that
what's the probability of that happening
sorry what what what is the probability
of there are bare men that don't have
housing and they literally find women
who have a child and they can move into
their house and that is a so so you're
right that that definitely is a thing
but it's a very small percentage of men
that can do that remember like i think
you've been here when i've talked about
these stats
and okay okay so 80 of women actually
it's 100 of women want 20 of men
so if you look at it and we have the
data to back this up because you have
dating
yeah so it's a very small part there are
a subset of men that do do that there
are the tinder swindlers out there
they're they're absolutely awesome and
they and they tend to attend
literally it's like a normal guy yes
road guy yes we'll turn up here
if we survey women it's they find 90 of
men unattractive or 80 of men on it i
can't remember the exact number between
80 and 90 of men unattractive like you
show a woman 10 men she'll say eight or
nine of them no yeah so it's it's a very
small percentage of men that could
get a woman's interest to begin with so
if you add on get
to get like free rent from her like what
percent of guys can get this yeah
but however they
you're correct you are correct that does
happen but what i'm saying is oftentimes
i think when we're trying to make a
point you're arguing an exception not
the rule yeah and and this is it's not
just you this is like i women do this on
my show all the time when we're looking
for an exception and it's not the rule
but it's a phenomenon that does take
place and yes but it's irrelevant to the
fact of the point we're trying to make
that yeah so does the solar eclipse the
point is
if i was an attractive girl i know that
if i go broke i can get a guy to pay for
it i can start an only fandom
but as a guy i can't bank
as a guy
no but but the whole point is that women
don't have consequences for their
actions because the majority of women or
the majority of men can't do that it's a
very small percentage but the majority
of women can't i know if i was homeless
tomorrow i could go marry a 60 year old
i'd be chilling
like and i and i just think i'm like a
normal girl so most girls can do that i
agree with you so like the point is
women get bailed out if we make bad
decisions men end up on the streets yeah
even for men that try hard i think it's
only 20 to 30 of men are actually
sexually active yeah so there's a whole
other
demographic of men that don't even get
afforded the chance to have sexual
intercourse
and that's the rate of women that are
sexually i think it's 90
100 no matter what you look like
sorry
once they reach a certain age it's like
okay so no matter what you look like
is it like 80 or so 100 percent
okay okay if you were if you were in the
dating market would it be hard to find
someone to sleep with you
no okay
you're dating right are you single
you're single okay would do you think
it's hard to find a guy to sleep with
you
no yeah i wouldn't think yeah okay so
you think for most what did you say
i'll make this point so the most
attractive man
could still go into a club and come out
of no one but one of the most least
attractive women could go into the club
and still come out with someone to sleep
and should come out with attractive
women that have exactly that same rate
and they would be like i'm attracted
most people find me attractive i can't
get a man that she wants yeah let's say
you go
she can't get a man that she wants oh
that's saying that
he's gonna sleep with anyone no i'm
saying that he he can go into a club and
still walk her empty-handed even if he
tries to graft on girls but also to add
to that with anyone now but also to add
to that with men yo it's different our
standards are different for what we will
sleep with here
compared to what we will be in a
relationship with like there's a lot of
girls that have had sex with guys that
are well out of their league because my
man just wanted to bust a knot with a
woman it's not like that dude i mean a
lot of women have to respect something
about you or rate something about you to
sleep with you my man could just be like
you know what she had a fat back bro
and leading on to the yeah that's where
some women get [ __ ] up because they
start sleeping they're saying a five and
they start sleeping with a ten and if
that's more level
but if he doesn't actually want to be in
a relationship with you my love that's
not your level that's it
but the whole the whole point is like as
a girl like we can just go down in looks
right if like so if a girl is a six say
she can go down to get get a rich three
that's 25 years older be bailed out of
any bad decision she's ever made it's
not it's not that hard but i think there
are men that can no no but i'm saying
i'm saying what percent of men do you
really think can do that
i i don't know what the percentage if
you get all men that could do that but
we would agree would you agree it's a
very small percentage less than five
percent no it's not that you think it's
higher so why would you say it's higher
than that more women that are making
good money so so then their ratio of
being able to get a woman who is making
good money and they can live off her
goes up every year the more women that
are making so why would you say it's
higher than that when dating app data so
these are two separate studies right
they surveyed women and asked them what
men they found attractive and they said
less than nine less than twenty percent
of men they found attractive and on
dating apps when women swiped right they
found less than twenty percent of men
attractive because okay yeah go ahead
okay so when you're swiping or the
evidence is placed in front of you
you're going to be way more in your this
is what i'm after now when you're face
to face with somebody and you're hearing
their baritones and you're feeling their
pheromones and they're in front of your
face that will probably drop a little
bit more okay depending on if you're
ovulating if you're horny if they're
ready to go things change so data when
you're swiping on faces is very one way
i i agree with you so i i do think like
there are things that men can do right
they can be funny they can you know
they're like
you're right but i